hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Minecraft I am
starting to get a lot more intelligent
when it comes to this game my IQ is
skyrocketing and also I realized I live
in a you know hole in the ground it only
took me three hours of playing in this
world to realize that I am content with
living in a hole in the ground and that
is not gonna be what is me I am gonna do
so much more than being a hole in the
ground and you know why because I
realized something about this enchanting
table I realized something but you
didn't tell me about it I realized it I
remembered something from early days of
Minecraft okay I remembered that if you
surround it with bookshelves it gets
better at enchanting I remember this
this is definitely a thing I am certain
that it's a thing okay I'm almost 100%
positive that it is a thing so what a
mud of you is I'm going to start my
sugarcane farm so that I can make more
paper so that I can make more
bookshelves all right it's fine you know
that's that's fine that is in fact fine
alright but that's that's also not the
point of whatever I'm what I'm doing I
did the can my brain is so huge that
sometimes my own thoughts get in the way
of what I'm saying yes I may live in a
hole in the ground at least it's a nice
hole but just bear with me okay it's
bear with me everybody just bear with me
okay I'm using my brain so everyone
better stand back because there's about
to be an explosion of genius click see
and replaced me saying genius with
genius of John
because I am Jenya sizing okay all right
there
maybe I shouldn't have put it in the
water it's probably fine so that's gonna
take some time to grow so I'm gonna do a
little time lapse I'm gonna go down and
I'm actually gonna just start I'm gonna
I'm gonna MIT I'm gonna make I'm gonna
dig straight down John yes because I
would hear the lava before I land on it
[Music]
scared me there for a second
[Music]
I've reached bedrock with no trouble
anyone that thinks that it's not a good
strategy to just dig straight down as an
idiot and I'm so much smarter than them
how dare anyone believe that it's not a
good strategy it's foolproof in every
way and I am a genius for even trying it
never one Quivers and fear at the amount
of brain that I have in my head and
anyone that doubts it is an idiot more
than they could possibly even think that
they're dumb which they can't touch
they're dumb I'm out of ladders
staircase perfect perfect is it busy is
it faze me lemon my squeezes my squeezes
have been wetting is it night I'll just
sleep does sleeping accelerate the
growth cycle because if it does that's
good if it doesn't I hate it
I need sticks Cavani just some more
lives or just doing to thank you I'm
very sick all right cool
yeah why don't I just build like a water
pit at the bottom of this that would be
probably much smarter idea and then I
could just jump down right oh yeah but
the way I built this doesn't allow me to
actually jump down this isn't very Jonas
level okay and I'm thinking that rah
here
I hear lava alright there's water there
if I fall I hit it and I'm good this is
where the riches are this is where I
shall strip mine and I shall just mine
to my heart's content and my heart was
is never content full of hate for or and
I hate it
three hours later I found nothing I'm
climbing out of my hole in shame I found
absolutely nothing and I've almost
burned through my entire diamond pickaxe
I was looking for diamond and I didn't
find it it's okay that's fine
because all I was doing is stalling for
time it wasn't really about the diamonds
you were fooled if you thought that I
was only trying to go get diamonds you
those aren't grown at all they're
growing a little bit squid get away from
my gosh darn sugarcane well you're a
little bit taller
that's good yes just I can plant more
you know I'm not gonna be dumb and I'm
not gonna put it in the water like like
a dumb wood I'm gonna put it next to the
water like a smart does this control
faster oh well it's a bed I'm awake you
know why don't I why am i digging with
why why am i digging with my very good
diamond pickaxe when I could enchant
like an iron pickaxe to do almost as
good stuff without wasting the diamond
pickaxe when I have a surplus of diamond
pickaxe I imagined that I could all
right guys you cannot be laughing at me
because it is not my fault that is a
perfectly acceptable mistake unless it
wasn't a mistake at all in which case
quiet you pleb so what happens if I
enchant you on braking efficiency
efficiency would be good that gasps are
you in there
efficiency sure cool I guess it's good
right it's a good thing right
right it's a good thing it's a good
thing isn't this smart is this smart
this feels smart this feels big brain
all right I'll be back why bother trying
it's okay it's because I don't have my
enchanting table with all of its library
goodness and trust me when I say this
enchanting table is gonna be surrounded
by the most genius libraries there ever
was the amount of genius energy that's
gonna be flowing through the sky is
going to be immense I've got a vague
memory like a fleeting nightmare in the
wind like just the stance of images that
suggests when I do get bookshelves to
surround this creation of mine it will
be like motes of light will flow towards
it like kind of gush towards it and
that'll do something or other I don't
know it looked cool there'll be like
letters and symbols floating through the
air I think that's what I remember
unless I'm completely forgetting like
what this actually is I'm
I'm almost 100% positive that this
actually is the way that this is
supposed to go unless I'm not
remembering it correctly
or maybe he'd be better off trying to
find more sugarcane I don't know at this
point I'm just incredibly stupid and I
don't know the right way to do anything
to save my life oh that just puts that
out that just puts that that's but that
just puts that out this just puts it
this just puts it I could have swung at
it and it would have put it out I could
have just swung at it I all right cool
hey that's nice man that's cool that's
good to know that's good to know
I need leather
did I kill more cos i mm that's not
enough leather if I want to make a
bookshelf how do I make a bookshelf
bookshelf bookshelf three books
that's three pieces of oh if I kill
pigmen in the nether is that gonna give
me leather pickle up
[Music]
all right I'm gonna go into the nether
and I'm gonna look up I'm gonna I'm
gonna hit I'm gonna hit a pig I'm gonna
inch a my sword knock back sharp
sharpness to make it sharp baby make it
sharp all right I'm gonna go attack a
Pigman and I'm gonna assume that's gonna
give me leather I have no evidence that
that actually does but I feel like if I
could pull some like leather off their
stinky hides maybe they'll do me some
good
hey hey strawberry hey nether buddy
Alexian that's not family-friendly
replace it with like friendly jobs I
don't want to actually insult them I
don't want to be today
pardon oh you oh oh no someone's on fire
oh that's a shame you hate to see it you
really hate to see it man they all get
up in there they get riled up you know
maybe this wasn't the best idea these
guys are actually kind of tough oh hey
oh wait where did you come from did I
just make an enemy of the entire nether
I feel like I might have made an enemy
of the entire nether and now these guys
will always and forever be hostile to me
that leather no nope no no I'm tough you
are
you are so lean I am tough that's why I
thought okay I have a funny feeling that
I'm in trouble for the rest of the game
but whatever you know I'm too tough to
be messed with but they didn't give me
any leather so that was not a good idea
that was extremely pointless and I don't
know why I did that I don't know why I
thought that attacking a pig man would
give me leather but you guys can kind of
see where my mind was going right you
guys can kind of understand that that
has some sort of a logic to it and then
I'm not entirely a fool anyway I'm gonna
go find them cow and I'm gonna kill some
cow or maybe I could domesticate some
cow I don't know if there's a way to
like shear the leather right off a cow
maybe there is it's probably not a thing
might be a thing all right either way I
think I got
go on a cow killings Cree something like
that I'm just gonna go I'm gonna come
back until I find cow because I'm gonna
make book and I'm gonna make bookshelf
and then it's gonna be great you're not
a cow Oh cow
I see cow in the distance okay you cow
it's better give me chicken
you bug give me a whole heck of a lot of
leather because I need a lot of it play
a lot of it books are expensive hi Momo
Bible oh wow much does it take to make
ow okay one leather for a book I'm a
what are you doing up there MooMoo
hey man nice perch hey that's great you
know that's really great really glad for
you I'm not here for you sheep
yeah the way just here for the cow nope
ah well that's fine I think there's a
cow also like on the tip top at this
mountain like the king of the calves
some king still dies all the same cow
King kau kau king king of the cow I know
there was a cow oh it's on the other
mountaintop this stupendous mountain
cows well you know I'll just take the
floating islands out you know that's
what I'll do oh right this makes sense
sure yeah I'm coming for you cows come
before you hang on okay this is horrible
idea this horrible horrible idea a
horrible horrible idea horrible worst
idea I've ever had worst idea
definitely top ten worst ideas terrible
idea worst idea oh my God my hands are
so sweaty
alright I'm just dropping it's fine
totally fine
come before you cows you're gonna give
me your letter I'm gonna make a buck Moo
no boot I'm gonna make a buck out of
your hide
baby I don't know the game needs leather
either jump out of the skin or I'm gonna
cut you out
whoa no leather whoa that leather yeah
that leather no leather how are these
things not have leather Wow you thought
you could hide I killed your family did
you have to hide away really just the
one you guys can't even give me more
than one where's your cow friends cows
respawn in the world right they they
don't just go one and done and then die
forever right there they're a renewable
resource right sure let's go as sure
it's really quiet once you kill halt
against that sugar cane I think that
sugar cane ooh that'll help that'll help
into the water I go oh you missed it by
that much hurts just the same er it's
just the same okay more Shuggie King its
Blue's Clues getting dark but good thing
I'm protected with all my incredibly
enchanted armor I promise I'm not going
to kill you
it's just me the crazed cow murder her
don't worry that's just my nickname on
account of how much i murder cows but
not you guys no no no I'm Freya I'm a
friend of the cows and very friendly
done seem like there's any cows that
want to come out and play they're all in
there cow holes you know how cows
hibernate for the winter and the holes
in the caves I understand you die now
don't don't don't even try well there's
a bright light over there did I pop down
something right there that's beautiful
did I do that sound like a villager you
know that's one thing I haven't seen yet
no villagers hut oh no it's la baa wow
that's cool
it's probably a cow cave over there but
I'll let it live for one more day what
was it with the like though the first
level that I played in there were 10
kajillion enemies everywhere now it
seems like there's two zombies for zone
I don't have an epic conclusion to that
that sentence kind of drifted off
everywhere but don't worry about it I'll
make it up in the next Hey look out you
killed the parrot you jerk you jerk oh
my god you okay
whoo I'm gonna pretend that that's the
same parrot and not the parents wife or
husband that is now mourning the loss of
said parrot you know I may be the crazy
cow murderer but I ain't the crazed bird
murderer that was not my fault I I tried
to warn it you know it's not my fault
that was straight-up not where is my
base how did I lose I'm lost I'm lost my
impeccable sense of direction has
betrayed me all I wanted to do this
videos make bookshelves and I have been
able to make bookshelves I haven't made
a single book you're not a cow you'll
never be a cow don't give me that cool
yeah walk away that's what I thought
where's where the heck is my home okay
here okay here's the mountain I was on
the other side of this mountain
no that's dude where's my home where'd
the jungle biome go where's my home help
help
cow cave help how did I get turned
around I have no idea where's the
where's the freakin sky bridge that
there's the sky bridge that I built then
it must be over there
all the way over there it's impossible
there's no way it's literally no way I
refuse to believe that that is true
I almost have gone farther than I
thought hey is that someone trying to
shoot at me it better not boy you better
check that attitude mister Skellington a
much tougher than once I once were you
gonna kill another bird Mycoskie oh is
he here visit hey hey hey hey hey no no
aah life ow that was dumb where is it
where where is it I'm running out of
food I'm running out of time I'm running
outta life no I see the fires of Gondor
the
there's Mordor the fires of the fires of
Rohan the fire the fires of woe where
the fire is called the by the fires of
Gondor fires of blonde or bond or lawn
door the fires this is not my home
what where's my home how am I lost it's
because I put out the fires
[Music]
oh my god what there's the mountain but
I didn't go up what what that's the
mountain that I climbed up I went
directly towards it so it's got to be
over this way this isn't it either how
did I get so lost nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope no no no it has to be here
somewhere right
cow I spiked out I will kill cow I have
no idea how this is possible
I don't know how this happened but I'm
literally lost who are you hi hey buddy
can you help me find my home oh oh I
don't have any of this I don't have any
of it bye I guess sure whatever that was
useless you're gonna die and you're
gonna give me leather did you get me
London yes one piece many cows leather
yes no you did not leather thank you
I legitimately don't know how I got so
lost
is it more is it more that way than I
think it is it must be it must be I must
have come down a little bit to get to
the mountains so it's got to be farther
up than I think it is that's the only
answer that I can possibly think of I
just gotta keep going this way and I'll
get there eventually I will see it
because there's still at least one or
two little fires there so I'm gonna see
it from a distance yes here yes yes yes
Oh finally my home my sweet sweet home
you've grown nothing at all
I was
for so many oh thank you thank you yeah
that's almost insulting thank you you
are the worst and you're going to die
you're gonna make me watch you die
this has been great this has been great
this has been fantastic this has been
terrific terrific terrific I'm gonna
make paper please thank you and now I'm
gonna make books interesting interesting
interesting okay five books I've got
five books that's enough for one
bookshelf that's great great book yeah
bookshelf that's amazing I have one
bookshelf that's so great
that's wonderful that's so good any of
you know if I remember correctly correct
me if I'm wrong they need to be one away
I'm not gonna let you burn my bookshelf
I'm not doing that magma block I'm not
gonna do that I'm not gonna do that
spicy though it may seem I'm not gonna
let you do that point
bane of arthropods yes yes this is what
I've been waiting for all my life so all
I got it hey we got some growth maybe it
doesn't grow and you're not nearby or
something I don't know something stupid
like that but either way you got some
growth we just got to make this growth
exponential exponential then we're gonna
get more cows and I'm gonna get a cow
farm and then I'm gonna have the best
enchantments in the history I knew that
was a big that was a thing okay so thank
you everybody so much for watching this
has been fantastic let me know you think
of my genius in the comments below if
you wanna see more minecraft this
playlist check it out thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]